You know, at the time, my thinking was like, okay, well, I really struggled to get people to care about my ideas for money. You know, but like, what if I could at least get them to care about it for, like, for free? And so that's kind of what got me into open source. I was like, okay, it's a good prerequisite for am I on the right track. So I got started to writing like an e-book called the Robot Overlord Manual, which is, it's an interesting e-book in hindsight. It was like somewhere in between a robotics versus RL book versus math book. It's a very strange book. I don't think it's that good in hindsight, but I had a really good time.
你知道，当时我的想法是，好吧，我真的很难让人们关心我关于赚钱的想法。你知道，但是，如果我至少能让他们免费关心它呢？所以这就是我进入开源领域的原因。我想，好吧，这是一个很好的前提，看看我是否走在正确的轨道上。所以我开始写一本名为《机器人霸主手册》的电子书，事后看来，这是一本有趣的电子书。它介于机器人技术、强化学习和数学书之间。这是一本非常奇怪的书。事后看来，我不认为它有多好，但我写得非常开心。
writing it. And basically, like, a couple of those chapters made it to the front page of hacker news. And I think they all sort of had this sort of similar essence of the math was a bit different. But like the math helped motivate how to write the systems. One canonical example of this is like how like lie algebras can help you like represent rotations and robotics. And so those are really fun for me or using Lagrangian physics to sort of formulate physics as an optimization problem that minimized energy. So a lot of these problems for me were like very, very intellectually appealing. Welcome to ADSP the podcast, episode 302 recorded on July 20th,
写这本书。基本上，其中几个章节登上了 Hacker News 的头版。我认为它们都有某种相似的本质，即数学部分有点不同。但是，数学有助于激发如何编写这些系统。一个典型的例子是李代数如何帮助你表示机器人技术中的旋转。所以这些对我来说真的很有趣，或者使用拉格朗日物理学将物理学表述为一个最小化能量的优化问题。因此，对我来说，这些问题中的许多在智力上都非常有吸引力。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客，第 302 集，录制于 7 月 20 日，
20206. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we interview Mark Serafim. Mark is co-founder of both GPU mode and Core Auto. And in today's episode, we chat about his path into computing. It includes GraphCore, Pytorch, meta, and more. I'm going to have to take up the B2. hat because hats are not super compatible with my hair. Well, we're here with Mark.
2026 年。我叫 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起采访 Mark Serafim。Mark 是 GPU mode 和 Core Auto 的联合创始人。在今天的节目中，我们聊到了他进入计算领域的路径。其中包括 GraphCore、PyTorch、Meta 等。我得戴上 B2 帽子，因为帽子和我的头发不太兼容。好吧，我们和 Mark 在一起。
I guess Mark, maybe you should intro yourself. Sure, yeah. Thanks for inviting me, Bryson. Thank you, Connor. Yeah, my name is Mark Serufim. I've been working in, like, AI systems for, like, about, like, six years now. Most of it was spent, like, working on PyTorch, which is a pretty popular, like, framework for deep learning. But I guess, like, what I ended up being most known by was this, like, fairly large ML systems community called GPU mode, where we do things ranging from, like,
我想 Mark，也许你应该自我介绍一下。当然，是的。谢谢你的邀请，Bryson。谢谢你，Connor。是的，我叫 Mark Serufim。我从事人工智能系统工作大约六年了。大部分时间都花在 PyTorch 上，这是一个非常流行的深度学习框架。但我猜，我最终最出名的是这个相当大的机器学习系统社区，叫做 GPU mode，我们在那里做各种各样的事情，从
GPU education to competitive GPU programming, and we have a whole variety of working groups. Most recently, like, I'm no longer purely working in open source like I used to, but I helped co-found a new Neo Lab called Core Automation. Our goal there is basically to build the world's most automated lab and build the world's best model. And, like, my research agenda there is, like, getting AI systems to be really good at writing, getting, like, AI to be really good at writing systems code. And I think this will be, like, fairly transformational, like, really for everyone.
GPU 教育到竞争性 GPU 编程，我们有各种各样的研究小组。最近，我不再像以前那样纯粹从事开源工作，但我帮助联合创立了一个新的 Neo Lab，名为 Core Automation。我们的目标基本上是建立世界上最自动化的实验室，并构建世界上最好的模型。而且，我的研究议程是让 AI 系统非常擅长编写系统代码。我认为这将是相当具有变革性的，真的对每个人都是如此。
And, you know, so yeah, thank you guys. And I'm excited to be here. How did so what did you do before you were working on AI systems? Like what did you do before Pi Torch? It's a very good question. So, yeah, I had like an interesting early career, like pretty bumpy. But the way I got started in AI was like in AI theory. So I was a grad student at UC San Diego.
所以，是的，谢谢你们。我很高兴来到这里。那么在你从事 AI 系统工作之前你做了什么？比如在 PyTorch 之前你做了什么？这是一个非常好的问题。所以，是的，我的职业生涯早期很有趣，相当坎坷。但我开始从事 AI 的方式是在 AI 理论方面。当时我是加州大学圣地亚哥分校的研究生。
I was fortunate to have like two amazing advisors with like Charles Elkin and Sanjord the Scoopto. And they're like primarily like I said, I was in AI theory. Like I taught like seminars on quantum computing. I was like trying to figure out if like, you know, we could rewrite like axioms of probability theory using like game theory instead. And I had a really great time. But basically, you know, at the time, like I didn't really sort of have like a good understanding of like how important AI would be. It was more like I just thought it was really cool.
我很幸运有两位出色的导师，Charles Elkin 和 Sanjord the Scoopto。他们主要是，就像我说的，我在 AI 理论领域。我教过量子计算研讨会。我当时试图弄清楚，你知道，我们是否可以用博弈论来重写概率论的公理。我过得很愉快。但基本上，你知道，当时我并没有真正理解 AI 会有多重要。我只是觉得它真的很酷。
And I ended up like my first job out of school was at Microsoft. So at the time, like I remember getting like the job offer about a year before I graduated. And so I just like spent the year doing math. But I joined as a product manager at Microsoft, and I worked on a whole bunch of wacky things. Like, I, you know, my first project was selling Microsoft's display ads business to AOL, which was like an interesting first project. Sock 3-E compliance as well for Outlook. It's like very exciting stuff. Wait, what year were you selling things to AOL?
我毕业后的第一份工作是在微软。当时，我记得在毕业前一年左右收到了工作邀请。所以我花了一年时间做数学。但我以产品经理的身份加入了微软，并做了一堆古怪的事情。比如，你知道，我的第一个项目是将微软的展示广告业务卖给 AOL，这是一个有趣的第一个项目。还有 Outlook 的 SOC 3-E 合规性。这真是令人兴奋的事情。等等，你是什么时候把东西卖给 AOL 的？
So this was 20, like 2014, 2015, roughly. This is when I first started my career. But yeah, I mean, it was a weird project because I remember. at the time being fairly AI-pilled and like thinking like, okay, I don't know how big of a deal this will be, but I did get a sense of like this is a really important problem. But at the time, I would say there was this widespread view in the industry that this was sort of like a luxury on top, like as in like it's sort of a further down the tech tree because what you needed to do is to get like big data, which was proprietary company data.
那是 2014 年、2015 年左右。这是我职业生涯刚开始的时候。但是，是的，这是一个奇怪的项目，因为我记得当时相当沉迷于 AI，并且认为，好吧，我不知道这会有多大影响，但我确实感觉到这是一个非常重要的问题。但当时，我认为行业内有一种普遍的观点，认为这是一种奢侈品，就像它在技术树的更下方，因为你需要做的是获得大数据，即专有的公司数据。
And once you accumulated enough of it, the hypothesis was that like you'd be able to build very smart systems. But funnily enough, this turned out to be incorrect. because private data turned out to be less valuable than public data, which was like very, I think a very strange conclusion. But it was the reality. And so like it was really only in my last year and a half at Microsoft that I worked as a research scientist. So there I was like working mostly on like email intelligence.
一旦你积累了足够多的数据，假设就是你能够构建非常智能的系统。但有趣的是，事实证明这是不正确的。因为私人数据被证明不如公共数据有价值，我认为这是一个非常奇怪的结论。但这就是现实。所以，直到我在微软的最后一年半，我才担任研究科学家。在那里，我主要从事电子邮件智能工作。
So think things like, you know, the AI systems that would figure out that this is a flight. And then given that it's a flight correctly parsed information out of it, these systems have to be fairly conservative because if you got someone's flight information wrong, would be really angry. And so, but at the time, like, I mean, a lot of these were like fast rules-based systems, like more into traditional AI. I myself had worked on like the first like deep learning system to do this like contact extraction and email.
所以想想那些事情，你知道，AI 系统会弄清楚这是一次航班。然后鉴于它是一次航班，正确地从中解析出信息，这些系统必须相当保守，因为如果你弄错了某人的航班信息，他们会非常生气。所以，但是当时，我的意思是，其中许多是基于规则的快速系统，更像是传统的 AI。我自己曾致力于第一个执行这种联系人提取和电子邮件的深度学习系统。
But at the time it was considered too heavyweight because the model that I built was like around like 50 megs. And so that was considered at the time like unrealistic deploying fraud. And primarily because like there was again this thesis at the time that like you would want like a small model to put on the client directly, that it would. wouldn't really make sense to have a central one because maybe people's preferences would be different. But it was interesting to me, like basically we were sort of correct in formulating the problem, but because we had certain ideological beliefs, like one about private data and two, about local models,
但当时它被认为太笨重了，因为我构建的模型大约有 50 兆。因此，在当时被认为是不切实际的部署。主要是因为当时又有这样一种论点，即你想要一个小模型直接放在客户端上，拥有一个中央模型并没有什么意义，因为人们的偏好可能不同。但这对我来说很有趣，基本上我们在制定问题方面是正确的，但因为我们有某些意识形态的信念，一个是关于私人数据的，另一个是关于本地模型的，
I would say that prevented us from building, like, really, like a state-of-the-art model that people could use. So, yeah, it's a longer story, but that was the Microsoft days. And let me know if you want me to keep going, if you want to interrupt me here. Because there's like maybe three more years, basically, worth of stuff that I can do. Yeah, yeah, I mean, keep going. Keep going. I'll keep going. Okay. So after Microsoft, I remember at the time feeling like it was around the time when the Dota AI bots came out.
我会说这阻止了我们构建人们可以使用的真正最先进的模型。所以，是的，这是一个更长的故事，但那是微软的日子。如果你想让我继续，或者你想在这里打断我，请告诉我。因为基本上还有大约三年的事情我可以讲。是的，是的，我的意思是，继续。继续。我会继续。好的。在微软之后，我记得当时感觉就像 Dota AI 机器人出现的时候。
And so for me, this was a like, this was kind of like in the same way I see a lot of younger folks feeling the same way about alums today. Like that was sort of like my field AGI moment. Primarily because like before I got started in working on software, like I got started in software because of video games. Like my sort of like my first experience using a computer to do work was pirating Warcraft 3 and reselling it to my schoolmates. So that was kind of how, that was my introduction to computers. I made a decent amount of money like doing this. But, but yeah, like, basically for,
所以对我来说，这就像，这就像我今天看到很多年轻人对大语言模型的感觉一样。那是我领域的 AGI 时刻。主要是因为在我开始从事软件工作之前，我开始从事软件工作是因为电子游戏。我使用计算机工作的第一次体验是盗版《魔兽争霸 3》并将其转卖给我的同学。所以这就是我接触计算机的方式。我靠这个赚了不少钱。但是，但是是的，基本上对于
for me, what always felt like the most magical was like, you see like an agent, like doing things on a screen. And to me, that always seemed like a, like, the real way to like look at the, like, it felt like tangible in a way that like, I don't know, grammar based models or like parsing trees, like never, never really did. And so, so my thinking then was that like, this work came out. And I was like, okay, well, this seems really transformational. Like, what if we could do this for all of video games? And we could have, like, really sophisticated game AI. And of course, like, I myself had spent a lot of time playing games like Starcraft and Dota. You know, I was a competitive chess player in school. And so, like, I just sort of quit my job and I'm like, okay, I'll figure
我来说，感觉最神奇的总是，你看到一个代理在屏幕上做事情。对我来说，这似乎总是，看待它的真正方式，它在某种程度上感觉是有形的，不像基于语法的模型或解析树那样，从来没有真正做到过。所以，我当时的思考是，这项工作出来了。我想，好吧，这看起来确实具有变革性。如果我们能为所有的电子游戏做到这一点呢？我们可以拥有非常复杂的游戏 AI。当然，我自己花了很多时间玩《星际争霸》和《Dota》。你知道，我在学校是一名竞技象棋选手。所以，我只是辞职了，我想，好吧，我会弄清楚
this out. Which turned out to me not, not like a very wise career choice for like a variety of reasons. One is, like, I'd no idea how to sell. I had no idea how to market my work. I was even that good of an engineer back then. And so, like, it's like struggling on all sorts of, like, skill issues. And most notably, and I think what ended up being like a really critical flaw of this work was that like, it was like really expensive to actually get anything working. And so like here I was like basically running on the equivalent of like a 1080TI. And what I would notice is like running sort of simple experiments within unity, which is like, you know, I would sort of change whether an agent is standing like this cord in a system or like increment the X coordinate by just a bit and
这一点。事实证明，由于各种原因，这并不是一个非常明智的职业选择。一是，我根本不知道如何销售。我不知道如何推销我的工作。那时我甚至不是一个优秀的工程师。所以，这就像在各种技能问题上挣扎。最值得注意的是，我认为这项工作的一个真正致命的缺陷是，实际上让任何东西工作起来都非常昂贵。所以，我当时基本上是在相当于 1080TI 的设备上运行。我注意到的是，在 Unity 中运行简单的实验，也就是，你知道，我会改变一个代理是在系统中站在这里还是仅仅增加一点 X 坐标，
like nothing would converge. And I was like very confused. Like these techniques felt really brittle to me. and it wasn't really clear how to get out of it. And at the time, I remember, you know, I was like mostly going off of like my savings from Microsoft days. And then COVID hit. So very quickly, like my sort of money that was like in stocks was like evaporating towards zero. And of course, I wasn't making income either.
没有任何东西会收敛。我感到非常困惑。这些技术对我来说感觉非常脆弱。而且不清楚如何摆脱它。当时，我记得，你知道，我主要靠我在微软时期的积蓄生活。然后新冠疫情爆发了。所以很快，我在股票里的钱就蒸发到零了。当然，我也没有收入。
So I really, really needed a job. And then I got a couple of them. A lot of them got rescinded because of COVID. So it was like very like, very like a weird time. And so like, you know, at the time my thinking was like, okay, well, I really struggled to get people to care about my ideas. for money, you know, but like, what if I could at least get them to care about it for, like, for free? And so that's kind of what got me into open source. I was like, okay, it's a good
所以我非常非常需要一份工作。然后我得到了几份。很多因为新冠疫情而被撤回了。所以那是一个非常奇怪的时期。所以，你知道，当时我的想法是，好吧，我真的很难让人们关心我的想法以换取金钱，你知道，但是，如果我至少能让他们免费关心它呢？所以这就是我进入开源领域的原因。我想，好吧，这是一个很好的
prerequisite for Am I on the right track. So I got started with writing like an e-book called the Robot Overlord manual, which is, it's an interesting e-book in hindsight. It was like somewhere in between a robotics versus RL book versus math book. It's a very strange book. I don't think it's that good in hindsight, but I had a really good time writing it. And basically, like, a couple of those chapters, like, made it to the front page of Hacker News, and I think they all sort of had this sort of similar essence of the math was a bit different, but like the math helped motivate how to write the systems. One canonical example of this is like how like lie algebras can help you, like, represent rotations and robotics. And so those are really fun for me or
前提，看看我是否走在正确的轨道上。所以我开始写一本名为《机器人霸主手册》的电子书，事后看来，这是一本有趣的电子书。它介于机器人技术、强化学习和数学书之间。这是一本非常奇怪的书。事后看来，我不认为它有多好，但我写得非常开心。基本上，其中几个章节登上了 Hacker News 的头版，我认为它们都有某种相似的本质，即数学部分有点不同，但数学有助于激发如何编写这些系统。一个典型的例子是李代数如何帮助你表示机器人技术中的旋转。所以这些对我来说真的很有趣，或者
using Lagrange in physics to sort of formulate physics as an optimization problem that minimized energy. So a lot of these problems for me were like very, very intellectually appealing. And yeah, and I guess eventually I started applying and like the only company that got back to me. It was this company called Graphcore, which was an old, I guess, now defunct competitor. You were at Graph Corps? For 11 months, yes. It was a fun story as well. So GraphCore was great. I had like amazing colleagues, but basically the sort of just like walking into it was we know we would basically go to these customers and we'd ask them, okay, well, we need to be deploying. Like, you know, do you want to buy our chip? And they'd be like, well, does it make such and such model faster?
使用拉格朗日物理学将物理学表述为一个最小化能量的优化问题。因此，对我来说，这些问题中的许多在智力上都非常有吸引力。是的，我想最终我开始申请，唯一回复我的公司是 Graphcore，这是一家老牌的，我想现在已经倒闭的竞争对手。你在 Graphcore 工作过？11 个月，是的。这也是一个有趣的故事。所以 Graphcore 很棒。我有很棒的同事，但基本上，走进它的方式是我们知道我们基本上会去找这些客户，我们会问他们，好吧，我们需要部署。比如，你知道，你想买我们的芯片吗？他们会说，好吧，它能让某某模型更快吗？
And we'd run a whole bunch of experiments and then, you know, it turns out with like a whole bunch of work. Yeah, often the answer was like, yes. The problem was that like, there was like two layers of problems. One was like, Nvidia wasn't a static target. Like basically we would do all this work. And then like a year later, Nvidia would just like double all the numbers we'd need to hit that always like really sucked. And then the second thing was like the world basically changed.
我们会做一堆实验，然后，你知道，事实证明，经过大量的工作。是的，答案通常是肯定的。问题在于，有两层问题。一是 Nvidia 不是一个静态目标。基本上我们会做所有这些工作。然后一年后，Nvidia 就会把我们需要达到的所有数字翻倍，这总是非常糟糕。第二件事是世界基本上变了。
Like I think GraphCore's like thesis at the time was that. So it was like a small Sram chip basically with like 300 megs and then later 900 megs. The idea was like if you can get a model to fit, it's incredible. But if it doesn't fit, you're sort of going distributed by default. and unfortunately, at the time, like, the Burt based on large, language models were quite large. And so it just, like, wasn't, like, a natural fit. We had to introduce, like, distributed programming, like, much earlier than the community basically was ready to understand these ideas. And so that was hard.
就像我认为 Graphcore 当时的论点是。所以它基本上是一个带有 300 兆，后来是 900 兆的小型 SRAM 芯片。想法是，如果你能让模型适配，那就太不可思议了。但如果它不适配，你基本上默认就是分布式的。不幸的是，当时，基于 BERT 的大型语言模型非常大。所以它只是，不像是一个自然的契合。我们必须比社区基本上准备好理解这些想法更早地引入分布式编程。所以这很难。
And, but, funnily enough, around that time, basically, was my first, I remember at the time writing, like, a, like, a very popular post called the Great Stagnation of Machine Learning. I don't know if you might have read it. That post kind of put me on the map at the time because it was, like, sort of this, like, the very, very off-the-cuff rant about how, like, most academic AI is, like, basically morally bankrupt because it sort of formulates itself as, like, this, like, innovative field that's, like, risk-taking, but a lot of it were sort of simple ideas, like, on scaling. And so, like, I think it was well written. I had a couple of, like, very catchy phrases in it, like, graduate student descent.
但是，有趣的是，在那段时间左右，基本上是我第一次，我记得当时写了一篇非常受欢迎的文章，叫做《机器学习的大停滞》。我不知道你是否读过。那篇文章当时让我声名鹊起，因为它是一种非常随意的咆哮，关于大多数学术 AI 基本上在道德上是破产的，因为它将自己表述为一个创新的、冒险的领域，但其中很多是关于扩展的简单想法。所以，我认为它写得很好。我在里面有几个非常吸引人的短语，比如研究生下降。
And there I was, like, attacking the auto-research community, which is now defunct. But I was also attacking the optimizer community, which is, turns out was defunct for a long time, but later had the introductions of like Mouan and Champu. Basically, they sort of salvage themselves. And it was like pretty interesting because like right after I wrote this, I remember sort of getting into trouble at work because like I was like also talking about like Graphcore about this. It was like it was like this very volatile post.
在那里，我攻击了自动研究社区，现在已经不存在了。但我还攻击了优化器社区，事实证明它已经倒闭了很长时间，但后来引入了 Mouan 和 Champu。基本上，他们挽救了自己。这非常有趣，因为就在我写完这篇文章后，我记得在工作中遇到了麻烦，因为我也在谈论 Graphcore 的这件事。这就像是一篇非常不稳定的文章。
But, you know, I remember over like Christmas break basically, there was like a job opening at Pytorch and I had started using Pitech myself at work. And my framing there was that like, you know, but like I started with Piano basically. that was sort of my first deep learning framework, and I remember none of them felt like a joy to use because it was just, I had an idea, and then I would get bogged down with how to implement it. But at the time with Pytarch, I remember,
但是，你知道，我记得在圣诞假期期间，基本上，PyTorch 有一个职位空缺，我已经在工作中开始使用 PyTorch 了。我的框架是，你知道，但我基本上是从 Theano 开始的。那是我的第一个深度学习框架，我记得没有一个用起来让人感到快乐，因为我有一个想法，然后我会被如何实现它所困扰。但在 PyTorch 的时候，我记得，
I was reading the UNET paper. The UNET paper is this architecture for vision encoders and has this very interesting structure where the encoders just get smaller and smaller, and then they, up until a point, then they get bigger and bigger. And I looked at this and was like at this fairly large architecture diagram, and I remember just reading the paper,
我正在阅读 UNET 论文。UNET 论文是视觉编码器的架构，具有非常有趣的结构，编码器变得越来越小，然后它们，直到某一点，然后它们变得越来越大。我看着这个，就像这个相当大的架构图，我记得只是读了论文，
And then just, like, typing out the Pytarch code without any reference. And then it just, like, worked. And I'm like, oh, my God, like, this thing is insane. Like, like, what is this alien technology? And I felt like I had to work on Pytarch and, you know, I applied. And I got very lucky that I passed interviews because I think a good chunk of my interviews, people just want to talk to me about my blogs, which was, like, pretty funny. And, yeah, and Pytar's was, like, one of the best places I've ever worked.
然后只是，像，在没有任何参考的情况下打出了 PyTorch 代码。然后它就，像，工作了。我想，哦，天哪，这东西太疯狂了。就像，这是什么外星技术？我觉得我必须在 PyTorch 工作，而且，你知道，我申请了。我很幸运通过了面试，因为我认为我的面试中很大一部分，人们只是想和我谈论我的博客，这非常有趣。而且，是的，PyTorch 是我工作过的最好的地方之一。
That's why I ended up staying there for, like, a whole five years. And, yeah, I mean, I just think for me sort of, like, it taught me. me a lot about like building things that people want. I felt like the engineering culture of the team was quite strong, but like even which was maybe rare is like I also had the product culture was quite strong. Like people really understood what is it that researchers wanted. And they had a clear idea of like their their customer base. This would change over time, but at least like in the early days I felt like this was like one of the best places in the world. Yeah, it's so fascinating to me the arc of how Pi Torch
这就是我最终在那里待了整整五年的原因。而且，是的，我的意思是，我只是认为对我来说，它教会了我很多关于构建人们想要的东西的知识。我觉得团队的工程文化非常强大，但即使是可能很少见的是，我也觉得产品文化非常强大。人们真正理解研究人员想要什么。他们对他们的客户群有清晰的认识。这会随着时间的推移而改变，但至少在早期，我觉得这是世界上最好的地方之一。是的，对我来说，PyTorch 的弧线非常迷人
sort of won as the dominant, you know, ML framework. Because, like, I remember when, you know, TensorFlow was the, the thing that we used for production, the big serious thing, you know, it's in C++, it's fast, it's got this, you know, you know, this declarative model. And, you know, I think at the time it seemed like
以某种方式赢得了主导的机器学习框架。因为，就像，我记得当，你知道，TensorFlow 是我们用于生产的东西，那个大的严肃的东西，你知道，它是 C++ 写的，它很快，它有这个，你知道，这个声明式模型。而且，你知道，我认为当时它看起来像
this kind of like crazy idea of like, well, just write it all in Python and, you know, be easy and simple. And people, people would ever do that at scale, but like, that does, like, how did we get to the point where, I mean, if I'm, if I understand correctly, like most of the big labs, or at least some of the big labs, do train in Pi Torch at scale. Like, how did we, how did we get there? Yeah, it's strange. And it's like something I've thought a lot about for what it's worth. But, but basically, like, my sense is that like, and this is like something I felt like a lot of the
这种疯狂的想法，比如，好吧，把它全部用 Python 写出来，而且，你知道，简单易行。人们，人们会大规模地这样做吗，但是，这确实，我们是如何达到这一点的，我的意思是，如果我理解正确的话，大多数大实验室，或者至少一些大实验室，确实在大规模地使用 PyTorch 进行训练。就像，我们是如何，我们是如何到达那里的？是的，这很奇怪。而且这是我思考了很多的事情。但是，基本上，我的感觉是，而且这就像我觉得很多
maybe hardware vendors with maybe the exception of Nvidia never truly internalized, which is that like if you ask a customer like what they want, they'll often tell you I want performance because it's like an easy way of like you put two bars on a slide and then you're like, oh, I pick the bigger bar. Therefore my decision is wise. But then like often like you realize like, okay, well, people want performance, but like they also want print statements and like they want like dynamic control flow and they want like ragged shapes and they want sparsity and they want all these things.
也许硬件供应商，除了 Nvidia 之外，可能从未真正内化过，那就是如果你问客户他们想要什么，他们通常会告诉你我想要性能，因为这是一种简单的方法，你可以在幻灯片上放两个条形图，然后你会说，哦，我选择了更大的条形图。因此我的决定是明智的。但随后，你意识到，好吧，人们想要性能，但他们也想要打印语句，他们想要动态控制流，他们想要参差不齐的形状，他们想要稀疏性，他们想要所有这些东西。
And this is like very like sort of weird for a performance person to understand generally. is. And it's obvious in hindsight, but at the time, I think people thought it was generally weird. And so, like, the way I think of it as sort of our job as systems people today. And again, I'm a sort of a newer systems person than you are, Bryce. But, like, basically, I sort of view my job as being at the service of AI researchers. Like, it's not to tell them your, the way you're doing things is incorrect. It's basically, well, they need to express their ideas and explore them. And it's like my job to figure out how to make this, like, class of people, like, productive. And turns out, like, it's not you write. You write. of training framework in like raw kuda and it's and then you expect people to understand all the all the details of the kuda manual and for what it's worth like i think the reason why like i would say this is no longer true today to be clear but i think the reason why this was probably true for a long time is because like memory bandwidth relative to flops like there wasn't sort of like this big dichotomy and so you didn't really like fusion compilers were important but they weren't like absolutely critical as they are today and so like pie torts very
这对于性能人员来说通常是非常奇怪的。这是显而易见的。事后看来，这很明显，但在当时，我认为人们认为这通常很奇怪。所以，我今天认为我们作为系统人员的工作方式。再说一次，我是一个比你更新的系统人员，Bryce。但是，基本上，我把我的工作视为为 AI 研究人员服务。就像，不是告诉他们你做事的方式是不正确的。基本上，他们需要表达他们的想法并探索它们。我的工作是弄清楚如何让这类人富有成效。事实证明，这不是你写的。你写了一个训练框架，用原始 CUDA，然后你期望人们理解 CUDA 手册的所有细节，而且值得一提的是，我认为为什么我会说这在今天不再是真的，要明确一点，但我认为这在很长一段时间内可能是真的，因为内存带宽相对于浮点运算，没有这种巨大的二分法，所以你并不真正需要，融合编译器很重要，但它们不像今天这样绝对关键，所以 PyTorch 非常
basically hit a sweet spot where they basically figured out that like a certain tradeoff didn't really matter for a long time. And then they figured out how to convert that into like a product advantage and basically all the papers are written at PyTorch. And again, in a world pre-LLMs where there was like a big variety and the kinds of ideas people were exploring and remember, there was things like Nerfs and GANS and language models and image models and diffusion and like a whole bunch of like ideas that have been lost the time today. Like these wouldn't be possible if like every time a researcher needed to do any work, they needed to recruit like a research engineer to do their job. And I think there's like a deeply unpleasant way of working,
基本上找到了一个最佳点，他们基本上发现某种权衡在很长一段时间内并不重要。然后他们想出了如何将其转化为产品优势，基本上所有的论文都是用 PyTorch 编写的。再说一次，在一个预大语言模型的世界里，人们探索的想法种类繁多，记住，有像 Nerfs、GANS、语言模型、图像模型、扩散模型以及今天随着时间流逝而丢失的一堆想法。如果每次研究人员需要做任何工作时，他们都需要招募一名研究工程师来完成他们的工作，这些是不可能的。我认为这是一种非常令人不快的工作方式，
which is like, you know, you go to the research engineer and then they're like, oh, grumble, grumble, like, you shouldn't do this. And like, this is a bad idea. And don't you spread. And, you know, that's not what you want to hear actually, yeah. I think that to some degree, like, if, if the research had stopped, if we had figured out the answer in, you know, 2019 or 2020, something like TensorFlow would have won. But the way that this industry played out is, like, the research continued. And that meant that the people doing the work were researchers and the work being done was exploration. And I think to some degree continues to be today. And so it was necessary to be able to move fast. Like, I don't know, maybe it maybe it's, maybe when people are
就像，你知道，你去找研究工程师，然后他们说，哦，抱怨，抱怨，就像，你不应该这样做。而且，这是一个坏主意。不要传播。而且，你知道，那不是你真正想听到的，是的。我认为在某种程度上，如果，如果研究停止了，如果我们已经在 2019 年或 2020 年找到了答案，像 TensorFlow 这样的东西就会赢。但这个行业的发展方式是，研究继续进行。这意味着做这项工作的人是研究人员，所做的工作是探索。我认为在某种程度上今天仍然如此。因此，必须能够快速行动。就像，我不知道，也许它，也许当人们处于
in a tech revolution, it always feels like this. But it feels like the industry moves faster now than it ever has in the past. And maybe people who are around during the internet revolution will tell us that it was like that back then. But it really does feel like, you know, like every week, every month, you know, there's some big new development. I mean, obviously there's some things have solidified, you know, it seems like transformers just take over most of the world. But there's still, you know, the idea of the researcher remains. It's not the production engineer, but it's the researcher, and we're going to explore a bunch of different models and, you know, that the productivity continues to be key.
技术革命中时，总是感觉像这样。但感觉这个行业现在的移动速度比过去任何时候都要快。也许互联网革命期间的人会告诉我们当时就是那样。但它确实感觉，你知道，就像每周，每个月，你知道，都有一些重大的新发展。我的意思是，显然有些事情已经固化了，你知道，看起来 Transformer 几乎接管了世界。但仍然，你知道，研究人员的想法仍然存在。这不是生产工程师，而是研究人员，我们将探索一堆不同的模型，而且，你知道，生产力仍然是关键。
I mean, yeah, like, for what it's worth, like I have heard people say things like, oh, like, since LLMs, this is sort of like, suck the oxygen out from a performance engineer's, like, perspective. But actually, like, I think even the label of transformer is, like, quite a broad one as far as I'm concerned when people use it, like, basically, you know, is a transformer with deltonet, like, can me,
我的意思是，是的，值得一提的是，我确实听到人们说，哦，自从大语言模型出现以来，这在某种程度上从性能工程师的角度吸走了氧气。但实际上，我认为即使是 Transformer 这个标签，就我而言，当人们使用它时，也是相当广泛的，基本上，你知道，是一个带有 deltonet 的 Transformer，像，可以我，
like, is this a transformer or is this, like, Arnan. Have you seen the alignment chart? Somebody tweeted the only... That's exactly what I was thinking about. Yeah. And so when I look at this alignment chart, what I'm thinking is like, okay, well, we found like an architecture that's really good. And then it's only natural that like people want to find some that are even better because like the amount of flops are putting into models are remarkable. Like yes, you can always get more GPUs, but there are sort of like economic limits. Like you can't get $7 trillion. Like a, you can't get a $7 trillion cluster easily. And there are like real bottlenecks.
像，这是一个 Transformer 还是像，Arnan。你看过对齐图表吗？有人发推文说唯一... 那正是我在想的。是的。所以当我看到这个对齐图表时，我在想的是，好吧，我们找到了一个非常好的架构。然后人们想要找到一些更好的架构是很自然的，因为他们投入到模型中的浮点运算量是惊人的。就像是的，你总是可以获得更多的 GPU，但存在某种经济限制。就像你不能获得 7 万亿美元。就像一个，你不能轻易获得 7 万亿美元的集群。而且存在真正的瓶颈。
the system beyond just money. And so, like, I continue to feel like there's, there's a big place for, like, architecture research. And I think for architecture research, I mean both, like, the kinds of models you pick or, like, variants of it. So think of things like a, you know, a transformer with residual connections or, like, with the kind of like the, yeah, so, like, is this a transformer? Like, yeah, kind of. Like, and so what are the tradeoffs there? And then, you know, turns out, like, those do have real tradeoffs. Like, for example, you use, like, a lot of VRAM for activations. You know, turns out that doesn't matter for training because you need to save for your backwards past anyways,
系统不仅仅是钱。所以，我继续觉得，架构研究有很大的空间。而且我认为对于架构研究，我的意思是，你选择的模型种类，或者它的变体。所以想想，你知道，一个带有残差连接的 Transformer，或者像，带有那种，是的，所以，像，这是一个 Transformer 吗？像，是的，有点像。所以那里的权衡是什么？然后，你知道，事实证明，这些确实有真正的权衡。例如，你使用大量的 VRAM 进行激活。你知道，事实证明这对于训练并不重要，因为无论如何你都需要为你的反向传递保存，
but it really matters for inference where now they use up a lot more memory. So, like, I, like, and I've realized this, like, especially since joining Core Auto, that, like, there is sort of, like, a big spectrum of, like, ideas that people want to explore. And then every time the research team sort of comes to me with, like, a specific idea or when we look at, like, papers and open source as to what people
但它对于推理确实很重要，因为现在它们占用了更多的内存。所以，我，像，我意识到了这一点，特别是在加入 Core Auto 之后，人们想要探索的想法确实有一个很大的光谱。然后每当研究团队带着一个具体的想法来找我，或者当我们查看论文和开源项目时，看看人们
are doing, they have very subtle tradeoffs for what makes them better, like, worse or better for inference and on what dimensions. But, yeah, I mean, I think ultimately the goal is capability. And so, like, that's why, like, You know, unfortunately, as systems guys, we have to accept that we're like second class because we want to see the remarkable capabilities. And then from that, we decide how can we best make this fast? Because if it was up to us, how do we design architectures?
正在做什么，他们有非常微妙的权衡，使得它们在推理方面变得更好或更差，以及在哪些维度上。但是，是的，我的意思是，我认为最终目标是能力。所以，这就是为什么，你知道，不幸的是，作为系统人员，我们必须接受我们是二等公民，因为我们想看到非凡的能力。然后从那里，我们决定如何最好地让它变快？因为如果是我们决定，我们如何设计架构？
We would just like, for example, send the same like weight matrix to GPU. It would be as big as possible. And then we would just do like a matmole versus itself over and over again. And there would be no non-linearities. It would just be like one giant matmole that you do infinitely and we get a GI. Like if researchers came to me with this, it's amazing. Unfortunately, such a model would not converge or be useful. So that's why I think inherently our opinions matter a bit less than we would like.
我们只会，例如，将相同的权重矩阵发送到 GPU。它会尽可能大。然后我们只会一遍又一遍地做矩阵乘法。并且不会有非线性。它只会是一个巨大的矩阵乘法，你无限地做，我们就会得到 AGI。如果研究人员带着这个来找我，那太棒了。不幸的是，这样的模型不会收敛或有用。所以这就是为什么我认为本质上我们的意见比我们希望的要重要一点。
And when you say you're on the Pytorch team, was that at Meta formerly Facebook at the time? Or was that like contributing to open source and you were working elsewhere? Yeah. So in my case, like I started as a user of Pytorch when I was at Graphcore and mostly spent a bit of time on the forums and stuff. I'd never sent a serious PR to PITR to PITR before joining the team. So when I joined it, it was like for five years and I worked indeed. I worked on the Pytur's team
当你说是 PyTorch 团队时，那是当时的前 Facebook Meta 吗？还是说那是为开源做贡献，而你在其他地方工作？是的。在我的情况下，我在 Graphcore 时开始作为 PyTorch 的用户，大部分时间花在论坛上之类的。在加入团队之前，我从未向 PyTorch 发送过严肃的 PR。所以当我加入它时，那是五年，我确实工作了。我在 PyTorch 团队工作
at the time the company was still called Facebook and at the time as well like it was sort of a like again it's all funny for me to think through this in hindsight but like it was pretty peak basically because it was like it was around the same time like
当时公司仍然叫 Facebook，而且当时，就像，这对我来说事后看来很有趣，但它基本上是巅峰，因为它就像，它大约在同一时间，就像
Pytorch was sort of like this like dominant programming language where everyone loved it was my first time working on a product that people adored as opposed to a product that we're trying to get people to adore which is like very different psychologically and then Lama 2 was also like a big revolution because it was like also So like a llama 1 was a good model, but its license was very restrictive.
PyTorch 是一种主导的编程语言，每个人都喜欢它，这是我第一次从事人们崇拜的产品，而不是我们试图让人们崇拜的产品，这在心理上非常不同，然后 Llama 2 也是一场大革命，因为它也是，所以像 Llama 1 是一个好模型，但它的许可证非常严格。
Lama 2 had a good license. And so like now there was this community building on top of it. Then you had things like local llama and like unsloth. And local alums were actually like becoming good. And Pytur's was sort of like the substrate behind that. And so I think for us for like those like two, three years, like it felt incredible because you really felt like you're like the good guys are winning in some sense. Yeah.
Llama 2 有一个很好的许可证。所以现在有一个社区在它之上构建。然后你有像本地 Llama 和 unsloth 这样的东西。本地大语言模型实际上变得很好了。PyTorch 是其背后的基质。所以我认为对于我们来说，在那两三年里，感觉不可思议，因为你真的觉得你在某种意义上是好人赢了。是的。
And then the work was cutting edge. And that was like, I think some of the most rewarding time actually to work in Pytritch was like around this period. Yeah, did you overlap with Adam them or had he moved on to other things? Adam almost never worked at Madda as far as I know, because he only worked at, he only worked as an intern, which is like a funny story. So, like, I met Adam for the first time last year. So like, because he lives in Poland or Germany, I forget, but like he doesn't fly to the
而且工作处于前沿。我认为这实际上是在 PyTorch 工作中最有价值的时期之一，就在这段时期。是的，你和 Adam 有重叠吗，还是他已经转向其他事情了？据我所知，Adam 几乎从未在 Meta 工作过，因为他只作为实习生工作过，这是一个有趣的故事。所以，我去年第一次见到 Adam。所以，因为他住在波兰或德国，我忘了，但他不飞往
U.S. very often. He's a bit of a hermit, but like one of the smartest people I've ever met. So I kind of understand. I kind of understand his perspective. But yeah, Adam basically was like the main person who wrote. most of the code for the first prototype of PyTorch. But then later, I would say, like, the project was mostly scaled up by, like, Sumit in terms of community and Adyang, in terms of, like, the code, like, basically CI and the
美国。他有点隐士，但他是我见过最聪明的人之一。所以我有点理解。我有点理解他的观点。但是，是的，Adam 基本上是编写 PyTorch 第一个原型大部分代码的主要人员。但后来，我会说，这个项目主要是由 Sumit 在社区方面和 Adyang 在代码方面扩展的，比如 CI 和
code and all the sort of, like, more hardcore features. And then, of course, like, the project ended up, like, I would say there's maybe, like, 30 or 40 people that I think were very critical to the project's success. But, like, you know, what I think of the founders, like, there's basically, yeah, there's, like, there's, there's, there's, there's, there's, there's, there's, there's, there's, there's, Sumit, there's Adam, and then there's Ed. For me, these are the people who I would consider it to be the OGs. And there were, of course, like, others, like, you might recognize, like, you know,
代码以及所有更硬核的功能。当然，项目最终，我会说可能有 30 或 40 人我认为对项目的成功至关重要。但是，你知道，当我想到创始人时，基本上，是的，有 Sumit，有 Adam，然后有 Ed。对我来说，这些人是我认为的 OG。当然还有其他人，比如，你可能会认出，比如，你知道，
Natalia, who used to work at Nvidia, who did, like, the most of our, like, Kuda performance work. Horace and Jason Ansel, who did, like, the majority of our, like, newer compiler work with Torch Compile. So many, like, many great engineers, like, touched a project at various points in time. But, yeah, I mean, like, the, the, Adam and Sumit did something more remarkable, which is, like, create something. from nothing. And I always have a lot more respects for that because I think scaling a project
Natalia，她曾经在 Nvidia 工作，她完成了我们大部分的 CUDA 性能工作。Horace 和 Jason Ansel，他们完成了我们大部分关于 Torch Compile 的新编译器工作。很多，很多伟大的工程师在不同时间点接触过这个项目。但是，是的，我的意思是，Adam 和 Sumit 做了一些更了不起的事情，那就是创造了一些东西。
in some sense is easier. It's hard. But I think creating something from scratch is not something that, like, I don't know, it's not something I take for granted or that I necessarily know how to reproduce really well. Right, right. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast.
从无到有。我总是对此有更多的尊重，因为我认为扩展一个项目在某种意义上更容易。这很难。但我认为从零开始创造东西不是我，我不知道，这不是我认为理所当然的事情，或者我未必知道如何很好地复制的事情。对，对。一定要查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用程序中还是在 ADSP the podcast.com 上，获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。
It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. All right. And before we get started, you might have to do a lot of the heavy lifting, Bryce. My Wi-Fi is fine, but my Deco-Mesh node keeps on, like, turning off, like, failing every 15 minutes. What is a Deco-Mesh node? It's a very fancy Wi-Fi. I have the same one.
这不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。好的。在我们开始之前，你可能需要做很多繁重的工作，Bryce。我的 Wi-Fi 很好，但我的 Deco-Mesh 节点一直在，像，关闭，像，每 15 分钟失败一次。什么是 Deco-Mesh 节点？这是一种非常花哨的 Wi-Fi。我有同样的一个。
Yeah, it's just like, it's not the best, but it's... up there. And it's just like if you want to set up a mesh network, which means like, you know, a lot of people, if you're in a condo, you can just have your single rotor that's fine. But if you have like a bigger space and you need multiple nodes, you can either like pay your Wi-Fi provider an extra like $5 per little Wi-Fi extender. But I was on principle never going to pay these companies more money unless if it's for faster internet. And so you can just buy these like, I don't even know what the correct technical term for it. Like, do you know, Mark? at like if you live in a new york in a new york apartment you don't have any of these problems you just
是的，就像是，它不是最好的，但它……还算不错。如果你想建立一个网状网络，这意味着，你知道，很多人，如果你住在公寓里，你只需要一个路由器就够了。但如果你空间比较大，需要多个节点，你要么可以每个Wi-Fi扩展器多付给你的Wi-Fi供应商5美元。但我原则上绝不会多付钱给这些公司，除非是为了更快的网速。所以你可以买这些，我甚至不知道它的正确技术术语是什么。马克，你知道吗？如果你住在纽约的公寓里，你就不会有这些问题，你只需要
they come in they put in one Wi-Fi router and it's always fast except for the last month they're pretty amazing by the i looked into this tech a while back but they do things like they try to predict for example like they can like measure which parts of your house like need the most bandwidth and they will like just route more bandwidth towards it so each of these routers is itself like this like interesting, like, statistical AI node. It's pretty, like, remarkable. I mean, I get, like, 800 megs per second on Wi-Fi speeds because of it. And before it, I was getting 30.
他们进来安装一个Wi-Fi路由器，它总是很快，除了上个月，它们真的很棒。我之前研究过这项技术，它们会做一些事情，比如它们会尝试预测，例如，它们可以测量你家里哪些部分最需要带宽，然后它们就会把更多的带宽分配到那里，所以这些路由器中的每一个本身就像是一个有趣的统计AI节点。这真的很了不起。我的意思是，因为这个，我的Wi-Fi速度达到了每秒800兆。而在那之前，我只有30兆。
Wow. Okay. Maybe I do need one of these. It's great. Like, I mean, if you play, like, especially, like, when I first set it up, I was just, like, download games and just, like, uninstall them for fun. You know, it was just like, let's just, like, waste capacity. Anyways, all right. Now we'll keep that in the edit, maybe, but I'll throw it over to Bryce, you can do introductions here.
哇。好吧。也许我确实需要一个。这太棒了。我的意思是，如果你玩游戏，尤其是，当我第一次设置它时，我只是下载游戏，然后为了好玩就把它们卸载了。你知道，这就像是，让我们浪费点容量吧。总之，好吧。现在我们可能会把这段保留在剪辑里，但我会把它交给布莱斯，你可以在这里做介绍。
But anyways, if I am silent for minutes on end to the listener, now you know it's because my little node is acting up. Over to Bryce. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但总之，如果我对着听众沉默了很久，现在你知道是因为我的小节点出问题了。交给布莱斯。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。